[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
field of dreams last night in iowa kevin
costner was there coming out from the
corn you had the yankees you had the
white sox it was great tv
and
paulie goes we need to get uh we need to
get frank whaley on my buddy i go
all right well he of course played the
young archie moonlight graham in field
of dreams of course he was in uh pulp
fiction as well we've been on the show a
couple of times good to have you back
frank um when people bring up field of
dreams
what did they ask
uh
can i spare a few dollars oh it's mostly
my family yeah
um how much did you get paid for that
role
um
it was it was many many years ago
probably i was probably and i was young
i was probably paid
the screen actors guild minimum
weekly
okay which in those days was
a few hundred dollars
but i was happy i was happy to have the
gig what were you told in the audition
uh
i
i i remember not not they didn't give me
the script i just had this that uh some
pages from the scenes that i was in so i
had to kind of deduce
my you know
myself but they they just told me to you
know to be to keep it natural as i
recall
and uh
you know it's hard to remember that was
many many years ago but i was
a lot of actors
in my age range at that time wanted that
role because it was you know it was
talked about you know what did you think
though when you read the script
i mean i i mentioned it yesterday when
you look at that and you go okay
um hey this is the uh premise for the
script and you're going
really
like that they're going to make a movie
out of that i mean costner said it's the
most dangerous movie he ever made
because he didn't know if
people are going to laugh at it and spit
it back out at him what did you think
when you uh you heard the premise for it
i felt the same it was it was a
different obviously a different kind of
sports film
that than you know we're used to
although i guess the natural had that
sort of
same same kind of feel to it but
yeah what i wasn't sure what to make of
it at all um and and you know i felt the
same way it was hard it was hard to
really know
how it was going to come out although it
was a really good script
and obviously had a great cast
so there was it was there was some high
hopes for it from my perspective when do
you meet costner
we all got together uh before we started
filming in california for for a
read-through and it was it was it was
everybody in this and then in this sort
of loft on hollywood boulevard
um assembled around this table and i was
a nervous wreck bert lancaster was there
james jones
i couldn't believe what i was i mean i
not not long before i was i was selling
like
various bodily fluids and tube socks on
the streets of manhattan and there i am
in this room
and there's bert lancaster and they put
me across from bert lancaster at the
table
and
and costume was there and and everybody
was really nice and phil robinson and
and
and the
the part
you know leading up to my first line
which is when i introduced that myself
to them and the and when they pick me up
on the side of the road
and and i was really nervous because i
knew my my time to speak was coming up
and i said i said the line is something
like i'm archie graham and
bert lanca after i said the line bro
lancaster stopped to the reading so hold
on hold on hold on oh boy and he said
that's the wrong that's the wrong
pronunciation
and i was mortified
um that and and he
he explained that it was graham which is
sort of three syllables instead of
graham which is one the way i was saying
my upstate new york twang and uh
he he he corrected he he worked with me
like three times on saying the line i
just i wasn't getting it because i was
so nervous and finally said all right
let's just keep going
and then i sat there the rest of the you
know the reading mortified feeling like
an idiot you didn't think you were going
to lose the job did you
of course
you always feel like you're going to
lose the job no matter what and and um
but
you know i i that that whole
i think that was the beginning of
everybody sort of being annoyed with me
um i still to this day i believe kevin
costner just is really annoyed he was
annoyed with me from the very beginning
why
because i was a wise ass and and uh
you still are yes yes yes um i began
very early
and uh and i just think
there was a there was a couple of
incidents on the set where i you know
i i crashed a uh
a golf cart into the side of a camera
truck there was all these golf carts
around
and i you know i had a lot of time
and i was always speeding around into
golf carts and i slammed into the side
of this camera truck
and
and i remember that was one of the
earliest
moments where costner was like he like
it was this if it was his camera truck
he was so he was really annoyed with me
and i was like what you
they don't they have insurance
should they have insurance
which was the wrong approach
but
um i mean that was sort of my you know i
was just kid running around you know
he's uh frank whaley the actor film
director screenwriter and uh he of
course was in uh field of dreams he was
archie moonlight graham the uh the
younger version of archie moonlight gur
graham
apparently
pulp fiction the doors jfk you've uh you
worked with uh brando costner samuel
travolta val kilmer tom cruise
uh who was the most intimidating actor
out of that group
uh
probably samuel l just because of that
the context of that scene it was pretty
scary he was he was
so good i mean he's a sweet wonderful
man but and that and that's in that
scene filming that scene he was pretty
scary so let me just create let me let
me play a portion of the uh of that
scene to let people uh revisit that that
anger that was there
check out the big brain on brad
you're a smart mother that's right
how many takes in that uh that scene
many many many many takes um tarantino
was a you know he's a perfectionist and
there was there was
it was a long couple of days and
i remember the the gun the gun shots
which are these like electrical they
call them squids these electrical
charges they put all over you
we did that a number of times i ended up
with all these bruises on my on my chest
and
um there was some question about how
close they held the gun to my you know
the and the guns to my face samuel has
gone to my face because there's you know
there's a certain you know
uh
standard to which the stunt man will
allow it and tarantino was like no it's
gotta be closer it's gonna be closer so
it was all pretty pretty wild and scary
but fun but since the scene is basically
you and samuel l do you
do you talk ab about the scene just you
two
oh yeah yeah no between takes it was
fine it was just
you know
yeah
it's
when somebody's that good and that and
that charged and and and
impassioned in their and their work and
their acting it's it's like you know you
kind of you kind of really feel it and
so you know but but other than that you
know he and
travolta we you know we you know we
laughed and drank coffee and talked did
you understand how
big that scene was going to be at in the
moment
no and people people ask you know
the same with field of dreams i mean it
it's hard to know that i mean you kind
of feel
the the sense that there's something you
know kind of
big going on um and
you know there's a there's a sense of
that
in the air
but it's hard to predict
you know i i was i was away
in both in both instances i was away
working on something else
when those films were released
and and i got kind of peripherally you
know notified of you know like this is
great this is great have you seen it you
know and
i i was i was when pulp fiction was
released i was actually in europe when i
came back i was living in new york city
at the time i suddenly was recognized on
the subway
people were like you know looking at me
and talking about me which which was
frightening for me did they call you
brad
they they were yeah they were they were
they were saying they were quoting the
film and
and
just kind of people in new york they
kind of you know just kind of look at
you and which is a little bit you know
for me at the time was
was frightening and
and odd because it hadn't happened up to
that point and so but there was quite a
bit of that after that film was released
i mean it's quite a resume that you have
here with pulp fiction field of dreams
jfk uh you were in the the door you were
robbie krieger in the in the doors right
uh the freshman is uh you know with with
brando born on the fourth of july with
tom cruise
these are these are these are all
high-end movies there do you still get
you get residual checks from all of
these
yeah but they're only at this point
they're like six cents yeah
you know three uh three dollars and 84
cents or you know
i i i will often like you know get lit
checks from like films like little
monsters that i did for like
like minus three cents
like i owe them it cost you
yeah i have to pay you have to send you
know you know so my wife was like okay
we all we owe seventeen dollars for uh
ruffian
uh did you keep anything from the set of
any of these movies
oh yeah yeah um
field of dreams i have
i have a whole bunch of cool stuff like
um it was the film was really called
shoeless joe
i actually have a shoeless joke cast and
crew t-shirt
um
uh
like these old field of dreams hats that
i think they gave out like stuff you
know i have a storage room that i i
didn't visit for a long time and i went
over there and opened the box it was all
this
really cool stuff
um do you think about jackets at the end
of these films like you know castle crew
jack because they just stopped doing
that now and i have like
like a whole bunch from that
um
i don't like a bunch of a lot of doors
stuff
and uh you know i'm yeah i always i tell
my kids that it's there when after i'm
gone you can you know have it have a
yard sale that's yeah that's what it's
for i was wondering if val kilmer stayed
in character when he was jim morrison in
the doors in between takes did he stay
in he strikes me as he would stay in
character yeah he he everybody you know
everybody was instructed to call him jim
um i defied that rule and um and he he
wore the same leather pants i think for
the entire the entire production and uh
yeah he was he was very much that yeah
he's very much cut from that mold
of the of method
uh and you know stays in character
and uh which is you know is what we love
about him
but also you know you see that
documentary that he has out now which is
fascinating and and you became really
good friends with val
yeah we became really good friends we
became really really tight on the side
of the doors um we're you know it's it's
it's it was kind of a thing where we're
sort of opposites and but we were you
know very close and
i loved him he he played uh uh in the
first film that i wrote and directed joe
the king
he played a character which is loosely
based on my father
and so we we became even even more
close uh on that and he
and that film i think he gives one of
his best performances than joe king and
but he's great in the doors and um i
love val um and and you know he's he's
he's an exceptional person and and
really an actor and yeah that
documentary is something else yeah i was
watching some of it last night frank
it's great to catch up with you again
hope the family is well and uh thanks
for joining us sharing some uh memories
thanks for having me that's uh frank
whaley he of course was in field of
dreams uh it's got quite a resume